thank you for joining us today for the
first link in chat that we have today
with our two experts on the new e rules
that will help you enterprises in doing
business on online platforms these rules
have just been published and they will
enter into force they will be applicable
as of next year we are ready to take
your questions already now and start
sending them on the comment section so
we will be able to respond to all of
them it has never been so easy to
consult your smartphone or and find a
range of options for hotels or
restaurants or city trips for instance
than today or via single online
intermediate or search and join these
online intermediates or platforms our
act as gateways for thousands of
businesses and millions of consumers but
these gateways should not add as
gatekeepers and make it more difficult
for businesses to to do businesses
online and offer their services and and
products so the U has realized this this
issue and that problems can arise
between businesses and online platforms
so that's why we have acted with the new
rules that we have put forward and today
we have our two experts Venice tank and
canning Michael canning to answer these
questions that you may have welcome to
both of you
so before taking the questions from the
audience I have myself first question
how burner these new rules will help
businesses and consumers to to practice
I mean to have a better practice so to
to be able to to benefit from the online
services better and why are they needed
yeah as you rightly say these platforms
have become super important for all of
us whether we are consumers or
businesses
consumers circus we all booked our
hotels on on platforms like booking.com
or Expedia or other platforms we buy
products online on marketplaces we
booked our we look for restaurants
through search engines and so on and so
forth
businesses of course therefore benefit
from this as well because they can reach
more customers than ever before and very
easily so and last but not least the
platform's themselves obviously the
intermediaries benefit from this as well
and we have 7,000 platforms in Europe
this is a very vibrant ecosystem that
potentially is good for everybody so why
now what are the problems
well many business users have flagged
concerns to us in the last few years
because they also grow dependent on
those platforms and I want Indian eat
and then they're excellent for them at
the same time you become dependent if
you sell most of your products or
services through some platforms you need
that platform and if that platform
doesn't treat you fairly or nicely you
still cannot walk away yeah so therefore
we try to address this imbalance that
sometimes arises between those
gatekeeper platforms as you call them
and the business users and the first
measure that we took was to improve
transparency for the business users so
you should know what you're up to do
what are the rules of the game and this
is very very important for the business
user so what the rules say is that the
terms and conditions so that defines the
rules they must be simple and clear if
they are changed
you must get information well in advance
before that you can adapt to those
changes you must understand how ranking
funk works so the way in which the
results are shown to the consumers you
must know how that platform may use data
that are generated when you on this
platform and how it uses those data
whether it shares those data also
sometimes the platform may compete with
those other sellers on its platform and
they of course it's very important for
you to understand okay in what way made
that platform treat its own services
better than my services many sing server
in there I mean for my code maybe a
question to you for now I mean for many
businesses appearing on search results
and ensuring this on page one rather
than page 10 obviously it
it's a key it's a key issue it's a key
it's critical and it can make or break
businesses the new rules will mean
platforms and search engines need to
explain how they organize this research
I mean the search results does the new
regulation on online platforms means
that platforms where n search engines
need to reveal and explain how their
algorithm work you know that ranking is
basically the intrinsic feature of most
of these platforms ranking basically
does a selection and trying to match
what the consumer or other users search
in the best in the best way and that's
why it is it is key and we also know
that you know if you appear on page 10
you basically don't exist as a business
and that's why we put a lot of focus on
the question on on ranking and indeed
the rules specify that both platforms
and search engines have to make clear
what are the main parameters that
determine how you are ranked so what are
the key features be it reviews for
example is it location data is it past
performance and other factors now how
far does this go it does not go as far
as revealing entire algorithms why
well a for most uses this would not be
helpful to get a lot of source code it's
just too complicated you want to know
what I as a business user do I have to
do to be higher up so it's really the
main parameters and not full algorithms
which at the same time also some of the
key sort of yeah features and and and
innovation features that platforms and
and these marketplaces use so it is the
useful information the key features that
bring you up for example also can I pay
to get further up and what happens if I
pay how far am I further up but not
technical questions around algorithms
many things before we take the first
questions from the audience I have a
last question for you a banner I mean
these new rules on online platforms
sound very practical if I am
this started for a small company how
this will this will work for me and if I
no longer for instance listed on an
e-commerce website how these new rules
will apply to me there indeed you refer
to delisting which is the practice
whereby a platform a closed your account
and that was signaled to us also as one
of the major problems business users
face because as you said you may depend
on a platform you sell most of your
products through that platform then all
of a sudden your your account is closed
and that may be for good or for bad
reasons because you may have done
something wrong you may have been called
selling counterfeit products but also it
may have been a mistake or it may be
something that you can easily repair so
now we have a couple of rules that are
very very concrete and real for business
users already in the terms of conditions
that I mentioned before the platform has
to spell out very clearly on what
grounds you may be delisted so what are
the mistakes you could be making if you
want yeah we also then say that when
once that happens you need to be
informed immediately and you need to
give to be given the reasons for this
and then very importantly it comes the
whole redress part that is also part of
our regulation so what can you do about
it if you are concerned with such a
decision
well then from now on you will have
access to an effective complaints
handling mechanism someone to talk to
there was something that was often
flagged as their businesses there's
nobody I can phone if I have a problem
now there will be a system in place that
you can back to the platform and say
listen you just solicited me I think
this was not correct and here's my
arguments and then you hopefully will
get the problem solved but the
regulation also helps you if that does
not work because we also have integrated
other mechanisms we are promoting
mediations out-of-court settlement
between platforms and business users
where they can't agree internally and
last but not least we also facilitated
access to courts if a platform
systematically does not comply with the
obligations in this regulation it can be
taken to court in Europe by associations
organizations representing the interest
of many of those business users many
things burner actually the first
question from our audience is not about
businesses because we
understand I mean how it could benefit
to to businesses but it's about
consumers so how these rules will help
consumers also to to buy online I mean
to benefit from the best offers online
yeah well the rules are designed to make
it fairer and more predictable for
business users for traders for app
developers to use these online platforms
and this has an immediate effect also
for consumers because they will see more
offers more innovative offers different
services provided through these
platforms and ultimately also because
you have more competition more players
more offers more competition on these
places ultimately lower prices to that
it's also important that the consumer
then actually also sees what is most
relevant from the consumer perspective
so not only there's a lot of competition
which is because the base is very wide
are often more choice but also for
instance where this a platform offers
their own services in third-party
services that there is no discrimination
then or undue discrimination between
those own services and those provided by
third-party sellers because I as a
consumer obviously I want to get the
hotel or the the good that suits my need
best and I don't care whether whom this
benefits most yeah I want to get the
most relevant results and and I think
this this regulation will contribute to
that many thanks to both we have a more
technical question now from the audience
do you classify what we call distributed
ledger technology DLT or blockchain as
platforms so are they going to be
covered by these new rules well I think
around these questions we always have to
distinguish on the one hand the platform
itself that is moderating the
interaction between business users and
consumers on the one hand and the
technologies they use and these are
really distinct questions and our
regulation applies to depending on
whether you know the platform is indeed
moderating and intermediating between
you know and offer end consumers on the
other side regardless of the
technologies it may use speed blockchain
or bleed any other technologies also in
the future
okay and for you Verner another question
which also interest a lot our viewers
and Committee on nicotine platforms can
enter the market and compete more easily
than traditional industry players this
will drive out these players and reduce
competition this can harm consumers do
the new rules address these competition
issues that's a very relevant question
and an important debate that we are
having the interplay also between our
regulation and competition policy and
what what contributes to that to that to
that issue I mean of course our
regulation plays an important role here
because it tries to establish a more
level playing field already between the
platforms themselves and sometimes
millions of business users that depend
on those platforms so there's a very
strong Pro competitive effect already
from this it also addresses some areas
like access to data use of data or the
self referencing of your own services
which are of course potential mechanisms
for very large platforms that have
privileged access to data and that may
potentially want to benefit your own
services to do that now the transparency
rules that we have in the regulation
already meant to to bring this more to
the open that everybody can see what is
happening and and challenge that but all
of this has consistently been
complemented by the rigorous application
of competition law that we have seen in
the last few years so where we felt
where the Commission felt that some
platforms were actually abusing or
potentially abusing their dominant
positions you have seen quite some
rigorous action from the Commission
doing so and last but not least the
story doesn't end here of course you may
also be aware of the of the
deliberations on the fitness of digital
of competition rules in the digital age
and there was a special report report by
special advises the commission of
aasaiya and they also examine those
questions and try to find out under what
circumstances may there be
anti-competitive behavior that may even
require further
King meshes and we are well beyond the
process of studying all of that material
those are monitoring the markets very
closely to see where and whether and if
there are regulatory gaps that may have
to be closed in the future actually we
have a very short I mean for the next
question very short question that very
relevant which also covers I mean
follow-up what you've just said how the
new rules will support innovation in
Europe maybe yeah both of you should I
start well I think it connects a bit to
what I said earlier I mean these rules
make it more predictable and therefore
if you want lower the barriers for
innovative companies to use these
platforms to go online because they know
now what are the rules of the game and
there's a standard which is a body of
fairness rules where they can rely and
say well I have a protection if things
go wrong you know I get my problem
solved if I have an issue with this
platform and that's will allow them you
know to use this more and offer yeah
more innovative services to consumers I
would add to that that there's also the
innovation element in the platform
industry itself because we're also
trying to create a more trusted
environment generally speaking because
there's a lot of criticism of platforms
these days but we want also new
platforms to come in what do you
European platforms to come in to scale
up in Europe and if we provide an
ecosystem where generally speaking
there's more trust that this is
following certain basic rules then
probably also new new new innovative
platform services themselves can come
into the market and probably challenge
some of the incumbents by doing things
in a better way in a fairer way in a
more innovative way I think there's a
pro-competitive innovation Pro
innovation effect across the board many
thanks to both actually are yours I also
want to know more about how we came out
how the Commission came with these new
rules and to which platforms we did
speak when we proposed I mean before we
proposed the rules could you tell us a
bit more about how you approached
platforms which with which one did you
speak that well maybe you saw okay let
me start perfect
it's a very good question it's easy to
answer because this regulation was
preceded by a very long preparatory
process which was also very inclusive it
already started three years ago with a
with a with a communication on online
platforms which was based on a white
consultation of the entire world not
just platforms but platform users
society in general so we already started
sort of gathering information on what
the issues were both positive and both
negative this was then followed by a
series of studies of consultations of
workshops of conferences in which all
parts of again society came in and was
able to provide us with their inputs so
in that sense we've been collecting
evidence for many many years and there's
probably no platform since you asked
that we have not spoken with and not
just the big ones but of course we were
particularly interested in the views of
smaller platforms as much as obviously
of this wide variety of business users
depending on any type of platforms it
was very rigorous preparation Chester on
the scope because I think it's also
important to see what is actually in
scope which is you know any platform
that inter mediate a relationship
between consumers and business users
little focus on Europe yeah so you have
to imagine this like a triangle you know
where you have the platform between
business users and and and consumers so
it's a classic online marketplaces its
hotel booking platforms its app stores
as well it can be price comparison sites
so it is really trying to encompass its
search engines for the key articles in
particular on ranking so it has quite a
for a broad reach to to capture the key
the key players but it doesn't only
apply to a certain layer or a limited
number of players or the big ones I mean
these are really fairness standards
across the board for for all platforms
that do business in Europe and if we
continue to enter a bit more in the
details of the of the regulations in
your regulation so once again which will
be applicable as of next year in in all
Member States of the EU if
I wear a startup and if I do not ensure
that businesses sell their goods or
services at the lowest prices on my
platforms no one will use it and cannot
earn on Commission's so that's the
situation does the new regulation online
platform stop me so this I think refers
to to this practice where where
platforms have specific arrangements
with some of their suppliers asking them
to really offer the best and the lowest
prices on the platform and not being
more attractive or having a more
attractive offers either on their own
website or on other platforms now here
we again wanted to to bring more
transparency on the use of these of
these use so to clearly answer the
question no this regulation does not
stop you from doing so but you have to
be transparent about it you have to be
spell it clearly out in your terms and
conditions explaining you know who wants
to do business on my platform has to
bring the best offer on my platform and
no Wells and explain the reasons which
very often is precisely to say well this
is for me a means to attract new
consumers and and avoid you know
distracting consumers in the end to
other offers which are more interesting
that's also that explains actually the
complexity of the question complains why
we limited ourselves to transparency
because some stakeholder groups were
asking for bands this has been examined
by competition authorities for quite a
while with with pretty mixed results so
it was not so clear-cut and also once
again if you read the special advices
report to a commission Avesta you will
also see that the experts distinguished
really between very specific situations
they did not say this is a bad practice
across the board and always harms
consumers or business users they said
well there are there very specific
circumstances in terms of competition
between platforms for instance which may
justify an instance or may explain why
in certain instances this may be not
acceptable whereas in others it may be
perfectly well acceptable but since we
are covering this wide echo system
of 7,000 platforms in so many different
in some in different areas of the
economy we did not want to come with a
one-size-fits-all solution that may do
good in some situations but harming
others actually I have also questioned
on that differentiated treatment I mean
I think it's relevant to what you just
said I mean is there any differentiation
between the platform's how what do the
rules say on this I think we
differentiate the treatment you're
referring to the those platforms that
offer their own services on their
platform while having third party
offices well that's the article on
differentiated treatment which was also
very hotly debated and I could almost
give the same answer that I just gave on
MFN clauses if you want because once
again self referencing is you also
sometimes call it maybe very harmful in
certain circumstances and pretty normal
in other circumstances so which is again
why this regulation limited safe to
transparency obligations yeah the
business user really has to know the
platform was a welcome to my platform
that's what I do be aware I may be
competing with you and I may be treating
my own services in different ways in the
following ways so at least maybe you
have a choice than to go to another
platform and not to this one or at least
it allows all of us to monitor very
closely whether those practices do any
harm that may then in specific
situations require further reaching
action yeah I think we should again
point to the work of our colleagues in
the competition field which have taken
up a concrete case where they look into
the concrete impact and I think the
insights in this case and the findings
will then also be sort of a landmark for
for the rest of the industry many things
to come back on the success of the
online platforms I mean you know you
mentioned that we have 7,000 platforms
in the EU and one of the question is I
mean platforms is often leaked to linked
sorry to how they use data provided by
consumers or generated from the
transactions do the new rules oblige
them
this platform this platform to share
this insight with businesses no it does
not require them to share data which was
indeed a request again from some some
stakeholder groups what the rules
actually says that they have to be very
transparent about what data they collect
what data they use now to use them what
data they share with their business
users and on what conditions but also
very importantly what data they may
share with third parties in a context
that is no longer limited to the service
that they provide to the business user
itself so that's a very very important
first step and as Mike just said this
competition case is referring to
specifically about data when our
colleagues are really examining to what
extent this privileged access to data by
such platforms may indeed lead to
situations where they abusively use
those data to favor their own services
and also actually some member states
have launched similar investigations so
we'll see what comes out of all of that
many thanks Miguel just to come back to
the redress mechanism to for the
audience to really understand how it
will work you describe businesses as
being valiant on online platforms our
business is really going to start
complaining or to online platforms if it
exposes them to some of some form of
retaliation for instance or meaning that
they will lose an important and or even
only sales channels that they can rely
on so how they could use this redress
mechanism in the best way yeah well I
think the starting point nevertheless if
you have a problem with your platform is
that you know you turn into the platform
and say listen if something isn't it's
not going well or I feel mistreated and
that's why we created this obligation of
an effective internal complaint handling
mechanism because too often we heard
that people don't get an answer or
they'd get an automatic answer or or
they directed to the head
orders in the US which which doesn't
help anybody so here platforms have to
have a response mechanism which which is
effective which is free of charge and
which is gives a timely response but the
other point that you mentioned is of
course a very important element that as
a business user you're dependent on this
platform so you might not want to make
too much of a fuss to be honest there
and that's why we created a
self-standing possibility for business
associations to take up problems yeah
that they hear from from individual
business users and bring them in their
own right to a court so they it's really
decoupled from the individual case it's
an association get them can say well
there seems to be really a structural
problem in this platform which is
constantly sort of not playing by the
rules so we go to a court and and the
court has to really hear this
association and as a result can order
the platform to change either its terms
or its practices or to engage in a
specific behavior which of course also
means that this individual business
doesn't have to quote even if it was
courageous enough to go to court it will
say what it can take long it may be very
expensive or that that code may be in
another jurisdiction outside Europe so
all of these problems or most of these
problems are solved through the
mechanism that Michael just described
okay very good
before we conclude this this life many
things to both I would like to come back
to the next steps on I mean the next
step for the European Commission for you
experts on platforms and if you could
just remind us a bit what is the
timeline for the entry for the
application of this new regulation which
will really change though also the the
landscape I mean the platform landscape
in the European Union food to take your
last question first so the rules as you
said have been published available in
all languages and they will come really
into application that platforms will
have to follow them in a year's time so
by by July next year platforms really
have to have all the rules and and the
transparency measures in place that are
in in this
regulation now in the run-up we we're
not just gonna wait and see we're gonna
work to make this implementation as
smooth as possible
for example we are planning to issue
guidelines on how to implement in
particular the ranking provision because
this is a key provision which is not
easy to to to apply in practice and
that's why we will develop guidelines
which come before for example we will
work on code of conduct for example
around the complaint handling which is
an area where it could be useful to sit
down with industry on how to best
organize this that all business users
profit when you want to talk about the
observatory yeah probably before the
observatory we also work with member
states because of the member states have
to play a certain role in this
regulation setting our bodies through at
all to enforces this regulation but also
probably the area of mediation so we
also help member states get ready for
this as well but we're also looking
forward at the same time because when we
propose this regulation we also set up
an observatory of the online economy
simply to understand batters better some
of the key issues that were so widely
debated during the negotiations whether
it is the data issue we discussed or the
self referencing or other issues so we
keep examining the space with
independent experts we study contracts
and ourselves of course you know in
order to to not stop here but really
keep an eye on the most pressing issues
many thanks to to both it's time to
conclude now we apologize for the
technical problems that our viewers may
have experimented during the life many
thanks again and we will obviously be
here to answer any questions that you
will have after this chat and we will
our community manager is here and
community and team is here to answer any
other questions thanks a lot to to both
for your expertise and your explanations
thank you very much thank you